man doing God do I want the world
you got your perspective how many of you
were collecting debt for college tell
truth that's okay just curious that to
me is like the thing that I'm spending
my whole life trying to figure out go
ahead yeah how just new guys college is
[ __ ] new in 1940 which is five minutes
ago not everybody's [ __ ] dream was to
go to college
I don't know but I know it's in trouble
you know like this conversation was not
happening ten years ago when the economy
collapses on the back of all the college
debt that all of you are occurring and
everybody blames the racket of college
for it
it'll be like banks or other things the
brand will be so bad the conversation
will change and I do believe that you
will be the generation of parents that
don't force your kids to go to college
so I think 30
I think Stanford Harvard I think the top
17 will be able to hold on a little bit
longer just on brand but I think the
really good schools like the state
schools like kind of that upper-middle I
think they're very vulnerable Michigan
is an amazingly good school but
collecting two hundred thousand in debt
with that interest rate for a good solid
Michigan degree in the real life the day
after no way
yeah I'm gonna get all that so this
machine that is stupid now gets really
smart because we'll go from 280 to 590
in revenue in 24 months it'll be
profitable revenue because the world
will melt and I'll be able to hire all
the people from other agencies for 25
cents on the dollar at the same time a
bunch of companies are gonna be over
leveraged and I'm gonna go out of
business and I'm gonna be able to buy
those businesses with the cash flow of
the 590 at higher revenue then the
economy should turn back in 12 years and
I'll be able to sell those businesses at
the frothy end and buy the Jets Super
Bowls you see what I'm doing I'm playing
the reverse game so everybody thinks
it's stupid now because they don't
understand it's over valued then it's
gonna seem very smart and then I maybe
will show this video and be like it
wasn't an accident which will only
compound the smarts of it and I'll be 62
and have 40 years to play all on the
equity of like pulling off a billion
dollar thing on smarts not luck on
humility of eating [ __ ] for a decade in
my prime right like kids are gonna watch
these videos and be like he was [ __ ]
39 he was 42 like I'm 26 and he was
patient that's why it worked I'm gonna
do nobody's ever seen anybody playing we
didn't get to watch Steve Jobs his first
nine years I'm not that I'm Matt or this
and that just like we didn't get to see
Bezos packing books no powerful and be
right now how many views do you think
how many you know how many views do you
think if Jeff Bezos was doing a blog
those first 50 episodes of him packing
books in a [ __ ] garage would happen
80 million maybe a fourteen billion
right everybody would watch it I mean
everybody yeah so how'd you like to
watch Michael Jordan's first three off
seasons and the work he put in so
there's a lot of thought that goes into
what I do that I don't speak about or I
show glimpses of and things like this my
team talks a lot about like me not
talking about being smart as you guys
know like none of my content is
okay done being smart that's just gonna
speak for itself when it's all said and
done I don't need people to think I'm
smart if you want a BMW on money you
don't have because you want to look good
amongst your pure set that you've made
it and you haven't you will lose you'll
lose especially during this era right
now where the market is good if you're
not winning right now you really [ __ ]
suck it's the truth because this is not
[ __ ] you know 2001 this is not 2008
you know any less people buy water
filtration systems when the [ __ ]
market collapses less people give me
less people buy [ __ ] cases of $4,000
wine like today this is happening at
Wine Library when the market collapses
less people you know many less people
are buying [ __ ] homes a lot less
people
real life and like what's so fun for me
is this is 100% I will not live the rest
of my life in a bullish market and
growth
so like recalling like I can't wait to
air this content the day the whole
[ __ ] world melts and it's gonna be
like I told you so and I hope you did
something about it because now it gets
really weird I'm gonna be so right about
that I'm gonna be so historically right
about that they're lending money to kids
in huge that there's nothing else to say
there's nothing else to say the banks
are doing it again
this time it's not [ __ ] Morgan
things you guys understand better I
don't still don't fully I mean I
understand packaging up or [ __ ] and not
having a true recognition or a true
system they're like you you guys
probably in the younger set you guys
know you have friends or acquaintances
who are 180,000 in debt a 9% interest
are making 47 thousand a year and are
buying expensive [ __ ] or have a new
apartment we're just we're counting
everybody else's points too much worry
about your own [ __ ] now that bubble will
burst and then we'll get to see who's
still around and then we'll see
everybody else who says entrepreneur in
their Instagram profile right now when
they're working in Bank of America in 24
months and so that's what I'm waiting
for I'm I'm I'm most excited for and
waiting for and hoping for complete
global economic pardon so that we can
weed out the B and C and D players
I don't think by the way that's where I
think this is so fun I think that is a
high note it's the same way I'm looking
at what's happening now the truth should
win if you're a piece of [ __ ] you should
lose if you're not a good entrepreneur
you should have a job merit and the
truth are always the winners in the
macro we're just in a micro right now
and people are confused and God do I
want the world you know why people are
confused everybody thinks I want the
world to melt because I do a bad job
communicating because I like keeping a
lot of [ __ ] in that I'm gonna take
advantage of it I want the world to melt
because people are gonna be happier
that's really interesting Tom people are
in fake environments no listen this is
why tom smart man he gets it he gets it
right away
I'm serious people can be happier
because everybody's living a fake life
right now and keeping up with the
Joneses and when everything melts
everybody gets back to the right not
paying the piper in 2009 in America for
the economic melting and going through
seven years of a recession and us
propping up [ __ ] our culture in a way
that nobody talks about
have you read the stand by Stephen King
I don't of course I already knew the
answer so here we go yes because it
literally speaks for exactly this this
the center character of the book is
somebody who's just popping off as a
musician right when this world ending
flu happens but the guy survives and so
he goes from everybody loves me they're
treating it as well I've got free
cocaine and then now no one knows who
the [ __ ] I am and that whole machinery
that was about to make me like the
biggest thing in the planet just fell
out from under him and he stole oh and
what's not so low because there's you
know enough people to survive but he
realizes like all that [ __ ] that he
was chasing now that just doesn't exist
so there's like the simplification of
life and to your point as he gets beyond
that hunger for the fame and the
adulation and just has to deal with
staying alive like his life actually
gets better I love this [ __ ] so [ __ ] God
can I not wait for the economic meltdown
because it's the beginning of happiness
at a bigger scale
[Music]